my name is mathias and i am the
founder of datatec data tab is a
web app for statistical data analysis
with which you
can analyze your data directly online without stress and it's that easy
go first to the statistics
online calculator for this on date up
de  and click on statistics calculator
click on learn table and insert your
own data here make
sure that the variable name is in the first row
i'll just use the example if
you copied your own data
here you can now see the
different variables that duh
analyze below  in these tabs
you will find all the methods you
need to evaluate your data
in the first part you will find the methods
for descriptive statistics you
can, for example, have them output the mean
value or the standard deviation or calculate a cross table or a
frequency table you are stuck
eg income and age and then
average standard  deviation you get
the table for the income
and the age with the mean value and the
standard deviation you click for
example the nominal variable place
and on frequency you get a
frequency table if
you want to add the gender
you get a cross table with
the variable  gender and the variable
location the next day you can
calculate a variety of hypothesis tests
for example you have your survey
asking men and women about their salary
and now you want to know if there is
a difference in the salary between
men and women you
just click the metric  variable
income and the nominal variable gender
datatec you now automatically calculate
an independent test and here below
you can see the results are the
prerequisites not met you can
also calculate the non-parametric test
the mcnew test and you will
immediately get its results again had
a nominal  variable  If there are more than two
expressions, for example the word,
a variance analysis is automatically
calculated, so depending on which
variable won clicks, you
will be suggested a suitable test, I
would say just try it
yourself, it’s very easy,
on this day you can then
calculate a coalition analysis  either
the pierson coalition or the spd dran
correlation and then down here you get
your results in the
regression tab it
can calculate a regression analysis fee for
just no dependent variable on and
the independent variable and price
automatically calculate whether it's a logistic or
a linear regression  you should
also be able to
calculate a main component analysis and
a cluster analysis, so it
all went very quickly
for more detailed information, just
look for our tutorial page here
you will find detailed instructions for the
first steps with datatec and for
each hypothesis test  are you coming
with an additional tutorial
i wish you a lot of fun with data tab